en este vídeo hablaremos de la evolución
de la fotosíntesis en la tierra ya que
al menos hasta ahora es el único lugar
en donde hemos descubierto que ocurre la
fotosíntesis personalmente creo que este
proceso también ocurre en otros lugares
del universo pero todavía no lo sabemos
al menos por ahora pero recordemos que
es la fotosíntesis es el proceso por el
cual los organismos son capaces de tomar
dióxido de carbono de la atmósfera en
presencia de agua y usando la energía
del sol la luz solar producen azúcares
de 6 h 12 o 6 y una molécula de oxígeno
es decir todos
cabe aclarar que esta ecuación química
que acabo de escribir no está balanceada
para balancear la tengo que poner 6
carbonos entonces pondré un 6 aquí al
frente después tengo 12 hidrógenos aquí
y por acá solamente tengo dos por lo que
multiplicar por un 6 acá y ahora los
oxígenos tengo 6 por 2
estos son 12 oxígenos más otros 6 me dan
18 por lo que también necesitó 18
oxígenos de este lado tengo por acá 6 de
ellos así que necesito otros 12 por aquí
por lo que pondré un 6 de este lado y ya
está balanceada es importante que te des
cuenta de que esto es un asunto
importante
tú no existiría sin la fotosíntesis tal
vez pienses que tú no realizas la
fotosíntesis pero pero toma en cuenta
que comes cosas que realizaron algún
tipo de fotosíntesis por lo que al final
del día nuestra energía viene del sol
incluso si comes un animal ese animal se
comió a otro animal que come plantas y
las plantas usan la energía solar su
almacenamiento se basa en las moléculas
de carbono en su mayoría azúcares
después nosotros nos comemos estas cosas
y así obtenemos energía para hacer
nuestras actividades como vídeos
educativos pero la pregunta interesante
es de donde viene la fotosíntesis y la
respuesta sencilla es que no tenemos
todas las respuestas pero los
científicos tienen una idea bastante
razonable sobre el surgimiento de la
fotosíntesis aquí tenemos una
cianobacteria esta es como todas las
bacterias procariotas
y es capaz de realizar la fotosíntesis
por su parte los científicos creen que
los organismos que no son muy diferentes
a las cianobacterias probablemente no se
un ancestro de la cianobacteria que
existió en la tierra hace dos y medio o
tres mil millones de años incluso más
atrás en el tiempo y ojo esto es
bastante temprano en la historia de la
tierra la tierra tiene aproximadamente
4.5 mil millones de años y este ancestro
de la hacienda bacteria era capaz de
tomar dióxido de carbono de la atmósfera
que con la presencia de agua producía
oxígeno aunque ésta sea una bacteria y
aunque cada una de ellas es un organismo
muy pequeño ellas pueden tener un
impacto bastante significativo por
ejemplo aquí tenemos un cultivo de
cianobacterias cerca de fiyi puedes ver
que estas son cosas relevantes y por lo
tanto pueden contribuir de una manera
importante al oxígeno de la atmósfera
los científicos creen que los ancestros
de la hacienda bacteria a medida que
evolucionaban en la tierra
y empezaban a crecer y a crecer ya
crecer y a crecer y a multiplicarse
empezaron a cambiar la atmósfera de la
tierra lo que puedes ver en este gráfico
de aquí es una buena hipótesis sobre los
cambios de oxígeno en la atmósfera a lo
largo del tiempo esto pudo saberse al
observar algunas muestras de rocas que
son muy muy antiguas y observando
registros fósiles muy antiguos
intentemos entender qué es lo que sucede
aquí en el eje horizontal tenemos miles
de millones de años es decir tengo mil
millones de años dos mil millones de
años tres mil millones de años 3.8 miles
de millones de años atrás así que
básicamente cubre gran parte de la
historia de la tierra si lo queremos
poner en algún contexto los seres
humanos modernos sólo hemos estado en la
tierra por unos doscientos o trescientos
mil años
ni siquiera podemos mostrar el pixel de
ese dato en este diagrama es decir que
nos vamos a tiempos muy lejanos los
científicos creen que estos primeros
organismos fotosintéticos podrían haber
evolucionado hace tres mil millones de
años aunque no es completamente seguro y
todos esos organismos produjeron oxígeno
mediante la fotosíntesis que seguramente
fue absorbido por el océano pero
eventualmente estos organismos
probablemente los ancestros de la
cianobacteria llegaron a ser tan tops
que el oxígeno comenzó a purificar la
atmósfera lo podemos ver justo aquí
antes de ese punto el oxígeno de la
atmósfera era cercano al 0% y justo aquí
en el evento de gran oxidación cuyas
siglas en inglés son g
de repente el oxígeno empezó a tener
cada vez un mayor porcentaje en la
atmósfera
estas dos curvas representan dos
estimaciones distintas del porcentaje de
oxígeno a lo largo del tiempo que se
mantiene creciendo hasta los tiempos
modernos
actualmente el oxígeno corresponde
aproximadamente a un 20 o 21 por ciento
de la atmósfera y la razón del por qué a
este suceso se le conoce como la
catástrofe de oxígeno es que un montón
de organismos anaeróbicos se envenenaron
con el oxígeno así que fue un evento de
extinción masiva debido a todo este
oxígeno en la atmósfera pero no es una
catástrofe para lo que nosotros somos
porque nosotros no sólo dependemos de
estos azúcares de la fotosíntesis sino
que además dependemos del oxígeno
producido
en la fotosíntesis usamos este oxígeno
para llevar a cabo la respiración e
incluso podemos ver a la respiración
como este proceso en reversa tomamos
azúcares con la presencia de oxígeno
porque al extraer esa energía de los
azúcares podemos vivir ahora una
pregunta interesante es en qué momento
pasamos de estos organismos que son
bacterias procariotas a organismos con
células eucariotas que son capaces de
realizar la fotosíntesis en su mayoría
conocidas como plantas para responder
esto tenemos que pensar en la teoría en
dosis biótica y tenemos un vídeo
completo sobre este mismo tema en khan
academy la endosimbiosis nos habla de la
idea de que los ancestros de la
cianobacteria tal vez vivían en
simbiosis con alguna otra célula
eucariota donde los ancestros de la
cianobacteria eran capaz de aprovechar
la energía de la luz para producir
azúcares para
la otra gran célula a cambio la célula
más grande le podría proporcionar
protección o nutrientes así que con esta
teoría simbiótica nosotros creemos que
los cloroplastos aquí puedes ver células
vegetales que tienen cloroplastos
visibles creemos que los cloroplastos
están entre los descendientes del
ancestro en común con la cianobacteria
la cianobacteria sería otro descendiente
de esos ancestros pero los descendientes
que después formaron los cloroplastos
fueron los que empezaron a vivir en
simbiosis cuando que después serían las
células vegetales una buena evidencia de
que estos cloroplastos tienen ancestros
que anteriormente solían vivir de manera
independiente es que ellos tienen adn
que por cierto es muy similar al adn de
la cianobacteria además tienen sus
propios ribosomas que son muy similares
a los ribosomas que tienen las
cianobacterias
también tienen mitocondria por lo que
creemos que los cloroplastos
originalmente fueron organismos
independientes parecidos a una bacteria
eventualmente esos organismos se
convirtieron en parte de la célula
eucariota en fin por aquí dejaré el
vídeo la fotosíntesis es un asunto
importante y es muy interesante pensar
de dónde proviene probablemente
evolucionó en la tierra hace miles de
millones de años cerca de tres mil
millones de años pero hace 2.3 o 2.4
miles de millones de años cambiaron por
completo el rumbo del planeta ya que
llenaron la atmósfera de oxígeno matando
a muchos otros organismos pero haciendo
que la vida fuera posible para otros
organismos y algunos de sus organismos
fotosintéticos iniciales tuvieron
descendientes que terminaron viviendo en
simbiosis con células eucariotas más
grandes que con el tiempo dieron lugar a
la célula vegetal y bueno eso es todo
por este vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente